must-see TV for you out on Netflix today
it's called killer inside the mind of
Aaron Hernandez and Dan Wetzel was
executive producer this docu-series
Yahoo Sports national columnist who
joins us now how did you get involved in
this project in well I covered Aaron
Hernandez his uh you know story from all
the way back into Florida Florida but
obviously once he was a suspect at the
murder of Odin Lloyd and enduring the
long process of you know multiple trials
and all the different things Kevin
Armstrong a journalist of the New York
Daily News at the time and I talked
about doing a book and maybe you know we
just saw this as a massive story that
went beyond the daily headlines there
were so many there was such - the
different angles to it that you know
this could be told in a different way
and we partnered up with a company
called Black fan out in New York City
do you know mederma who handled the
directing and some of the executive
producing and kind of got to work on it
while in between the first and second
trial and at that point obviously we had
no idea we're headed you know an
acquittal and a second trial you know
suicide in the prison all the different
things so it's been a long process to
tell the story but we were there pretty
much from you know every day every step
of the way so I think we're able to
provide uh a depth of a depth of the
story that you wouldn't get if you're
just kind of coming in after it became
this big sensation how did he hide his
double life from Belichick and his
teammates and Robert Kraft
you know he had very different worlds if
you if you look at it his friends he was
hanging out with at times worthy and
they weren't Patriots he didn't hang out
a lot with the Patriots that's in there
he wasn't connecting with the guys on
the team which was a side of concern so
he would be out and with with friends
mainly this guy Alexander Bradley who
was a drug and gun dealer out of me or
out of a Connecticut and and they just
had different different worlds so nobody
knew what he was doing he was I mean he
was he had he had a million different
kind of hidden lifes no-selfie wrestled
with sexuality and try to hide that
throughout high school in college he
could he if you listen to the we have a
lot of the jailhouse phone calls in it
and if you listen throughout the three
parts of the series you'll hear him
talking in incredibly different ways to
all different types of people he can be
as kind and as sweet to us to his
daughter or his cousin or something like
that he can be totally different with
somebody else and so you just see how
this guy was really a chameleon but what
he was doing at night people have no so
you literally had in in 2012 you had him
at the very least involved and in in a
double homicide in Boston a shooting
where they drive-by shooting and then he
ends up stashing the car at his cousin's
garage either he's are the triggerman or
he's in the car with Alexander Bradley
about a few weeks later he signs a 40
million dollar extension with the
Patriot and employs an entire season in
the NFL as essentially an accused double
murderer so you just have never seen
anything like this in the in football
where a guy who's got that kind of a
secret life going on
it's truly football player by day at
times and gangster at night but there
were so many elements to his story that
were hidden from the people he who knew
him the best whether his wife or his
attorney or the way everyone who knew
him best was shocked when he committed
suicide he just got away of
compartmentalizing and hiding
things for people how much cooperation
did you get from the Patriots you know
there we have a lot of NFL footage in
there we have some former Patriots and
things like that but you know you
weren't going to have don't Bella checks
it down for extensive interview on this
which is understandable did Aaron
Hernandez almost get away with this
no he well he probably could have gotten
away with the first one is his real
problem was he got into a rivalry with
with his friend Alexander Bradley who
blamed him or testified at one point but
a very least blamed him for shooting him
in the face in a separate incident down
in Florida there's a lot to this thing
it's hard to to put it in but but he was
in college at that time wasn't he Dan he
was though this was after college and
Bradley Bradley became friends after
college but Bradley says Hernandez shot
him in the shot him in the I thought he
was thought Bradley was dead Bradley
survived
Bradley basically says I'm going to I'm
going to kill you it's revenge you're
refuses to cooperate with the police
Aaron loads up buys an armored car he
starts hanging out with a couple guys
who's kind of bodyguards he's got a lot
of weapons at that point it was a matter
of time what was going to happen he
ended up killing Odin Lloyd in and
getting caught for that you know kutia
gotten away extensively for the double
homicide being involved in that it's
hard to say still had the car kind of
sitting in a garage hidden in
Connecticut so maybe but I think Aaron
was you know he he only played three
years in the NFL he was only 23 when he
was arrested to think he would have
gotten away with it for much longer he
lived a life that was doomed to to
pretty much end up in some some for some
failure at some point or some kind of
arrest or the murder of himself he was
completely on the edge he lived it
completely outside the bounds of normal
society life while he's playing
professional football we're talking to
Dan Wetzel Yahoo Sports national
columnist and exec
producer the docu-series killer inside
the mind of Aaron Hernandez out today on
Netflix what did you learn about his
time in prison well again that too is
complicated I mean when he first went in
people you know he gets put on suicide
watch right away when he goes into the
jail and they usually do that with
anybody facing that kind of charges or
pressure of a life sentence I the the
jail officials before he's convicted say
he literally moves in it's almost a
relief said he just completed there's no
crying there's no banging on the door
saying I don't belong here
I need this nothing all he ever did all
his only request was more protein and as
a in his in his lunch and stuff like
that he just basically was fine with it
there's a jailhouse calls me talking to
his mom I don't much he liked to sell Oh
cozy it is and things but later on
through through it I think the pressure
of being so young and facing life
without parole got to him and I think it
was the the key reason why I ended up
committing suicide although we'll never
really know so after four years in he
ends up committing suicide and and in
the state in the maximum security at
that point he would convicted it was in
a much rougher prison and I think that
just kind of worn him down and got it so
he ends up killing himself with 27 but
very interesting dynamics there on both
an ability to to adapt immediately but
also struggle with with the fights and
the discipline and and just the sheer
difficulty of facing or would have been
you know 50 60 more years yeah he was a
wannabe gangster it felt like he's
hiding his sexuality you I don't know if
CTE plays a role in this is there a part
of this docu-series where the audience
is going to come away with you know a
scene that sort of surprises you or
blows you away I think there's a number
of them particularly the the phone calls
that really show him in unguarded
moments there's you know we took a very
journalists if we sound approach to this
we're not just chasing the craziest
rumor we can throw up there to try to
shock people like this is as you know
we've reached out to hundreds of people
and work this story for year so it's not
going to be something where we're just
throwing anything in there and shock
people but I think there's a number of
them I think you see the death nobody in
this in this Stocki series fits into a
box very well including Aaron Hernandez
it's real life it's there's there's
there's good parts and bad parts almost
everyone involved so he just uh you know
why has always been the story I think it
would be unfair to just make a
determination on that I think it was a
perfect cocktail of different things
abuse as a child is dad passing away I
think the decision to go to Florida
wasn't great for or much like CTE
playing a role probably or could have
you know an interest in being a gangster
all the different things and we're not
trying to excuse Aaron's behavior
because he made these decisions and
these decisions as we point out and
spend a lot of time with the victims
you know ruined lives ended lives
adversely affected a lot of lives that
had nothing to do with him people he
didn't know and but we do try to explain
system myriad circumstances around this
to try to figure out why we've had this
because this is just a story we've never
seen you talk about NFL murderers you
know OJ Simpson and things like that not
such a you know an incredible story and
its own right obviously but OJ was
retired OJ was caught up in domestic
violence like these are things we seen
before they aren't that uncommon in the
world sadly we've never seen this you
just don't see a guy driving around
shooting people being involved in you
know as many seven shootings and three
homicides all by 23 while being a
professional athlete highly functioning
me
I caught a touchdown pass in the Super
Bowl he's able to keep you know he's
able to conform with the Patriots he has
this beautiful mansion a loving fiance
the baby does everything at times to
show how I'm making it and then on the
other side he's do
something completely opposite and that's
just sort of the way he lived his life
dan thank you good stuff it's out today
on Netflix it's called killer inside the
mind of Aaron Hernandez great to catch
up with you thank you Dan for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]